supongamos que tenemos una
parametrización en forma vectorial r dt
igual a x dt multiplicado por el vector
unitario y más 7 x el vector unitario
jota y déjame hacer una gráfica de cómo
se va a ver esto este de aquí es un eje
déjame poner un poco más derecho este de
aquí es el eje y este de por acá es el
eje x y entonces vamos a ponerle que t
se mueve en un cierto intervalo digamos
que a es menor o igual que t y eso es
menor o igual que b sale cuando te es
igual a a estamos en este punto es decir
si metemos este iguala aquí arriba
obtenemos un vector que va del 0 a este
punto y luego conforme te va
incrementando su valor se empieza a
trazar una curva en el plano xy y se
vería más o menos así notemos que para t
igual a b obtenemos un vector que apunta
hacia el extremo final de este modo la
parametrización define una trayectoria
recorrida en esta dirección hacia
ahora vamos a dar una segunda
parametrización en forma vectorial
déjame cambiar de color y lo voy a
escribir acá a la derecha vamos a
llamarla r
r reversa entonces va a ser eres v r
eres v r no no eres v resuena súper feo
dejame borrar eso vamos a llamarle nada
más
rt pero es diferente porque está de aquí
es verde entonces es r dt y en vez de
ser x dt por iba a ser x de a más b - t
x y más y lo mismo con que llegue a más
b - t x j
esto ya lo habíamos encontrado en los
vídeos pasados la trayectoria que se
traza al considerar esta nueva
parametrización es muy parecida de hecho
se ve así dibujo el eje por acá el eje x
de hecho vamos a etiquetar los ejes eje
y eje x eje y eje x esta trayectoria se
va a ver muy parecida a la primera sólo
que ya no va a empezar aquí terminar acá
ahora la vamos a recorrer al revés antes
déjame escribir que también ahora a es
menor o igual que t y es menor o igual
que b o sea te va de a a b como te
comentaba ahora substituir te iguala
este vector de dirección y por tanto
empezamos acá arriba después conforme te
va aumentando su valor aquí moviéndose
de a ave se va trazando la misma
trayectoria pero recorrida en sentido
opuesto es la misma trayectoria pero en
la dirección contraria observa que al
sustituir de igual ave aquí arriba
tenemos equis dea y de este otro lado
llegue a las veces cancelan y el vector
director apunta hacia acá de este modo
la forma de las dos trayectorias es
exactamente la misma pero están
recorridas en sentido contrario lo que
queremos hacer en este vídeo es ver cómo
afecta a este cambio de parametrización
en una integral de línea sobre un campo
vectorial tomemos un campo vectorial
digamos
efe de x igual a
pd x por el vector unitario y más q de
xy por el vector unitario j esto de aquí
simplemente es un campo vectorial en el
plano x y ahora como la integral de
línea de este campo vectorial
sobre esta trayectoria es decir sobre si
se compara con la integral de línea del
mismo campo vectorial pero sobre esa
otra trayectoria es decir con la
integral de menos c vamos a ponerle
nombres este de acá es la curva ce esta
de acá es la curva menos ce y entonces
la pregunta es cómo se comparan las
integrales de la curva positiva con la
de la negativa de f de r va entonces
antes de que me meten las matemáticas
vamos a pensar un poco la intuición
detrás vamos a dibujar el campo
vectorial vamos a poner algunos vectores
acuérdate que un campo vectorial le
asigna a cada punto del plano xy una
cierta fecha o sea un vector entonces lo
único que nos importa son los vectores
que están sobre la curva sobre la curva
se vería más o menos así verdad bueno
por decir algo vámonos para acá es el
mismo campo vectorial entonces otra vez
ponemos los mismos vectores por ahí
sale lo que queremos hacer es agarrar un
poco de la intuición de lo que está
pasando esto de aquí es una suma estamos
haciendo una suma de muchas cosas verdad
estamos tomando un punto sobre la
trayectoria
es más déjame empezar aquí entonces
vamos a tomar un punto sobre la
trayectoria vamos a ponerlo en rosa
mexicano y queremos hacer el producto
punto de efe es decir este de aquí con
de r es decir la derivada de nuestra
parametrización vectorial y recordamos
que sólo podemos pensar como un muy
pequeño cambio así infinitesimal en la
dirección de nuestra trayectoria
entonces cuando hacemos el producto
punto de esto de aquí esencialmente lo
que estamos haciendo es obtener un valor
escalar que nos dice que tanto de la
fuerza está en dirección del movimiento
y luego multiplicarlo por la magnitud de
la fuerza y del movimiento en el dibujo
nos quedaría una proyección como por
aquí pero sabes que mejor déjame hacer
un zoom entonces lo que voy a hacer es
copiar esta parte y lo voy a agrandar
entonces supongamos que este de aquí es
la trayectoria y que aquí tenemos
efe en ese punto efe es el campo
vectorial ahora de r se vería como un
pequeño cambio lo voy a hacer con otro
color con naranja este de aquí es de r
este de aquí es efe y entonces el
producto punto de estos dos vectores
es que tanto de efe va en la misma
dirección que de erre entonces lo
podemos pensar como la proyección sobre
t r y entonces la magnitud que obtenemos
multiplicada por la magnitud de r es el
producto punto de f con de r aquí vamos
a obtener un valor positivo porque
tenemos puras longitudes positivas va
pero qué sucede si el de r va en la
dirección contraria como en el segundo
caso déjame dibujar otra vez el zoom eso
de ahí es la misma parte de la curva una
vez más tenemos nuestra f
entonces la f nos da un vector
estoy dibujando exactamente lo mismo
pero ahora la de r va en la otra
dirección por qué pues porque menos se
recorre en dirección contraria entonces
de r nos queda algo de pues un vector de
este estilo sale entonces nos queda en
esa dirección este de aquí es de r y
entonces cuando hacemos el producto
punto ahora otra vez vamos a proyectar
efe nr pero esta vez tenemos que
proyectarlo por acá observa que está
yendo en la dirección contraria de de r
entonces al multiplicar las magnitudes
deberíamos obtener una magnitud negativa
otra vez en este caso la proyección de f
queda en dirección contraria que de r
pero en el primer caso la proyección y
va en la misma dirección
entonces la intuición nos debe de decir
que estas integrales sólo varían en un
signo menos vámonos a las matemáticas
para intentar demostrar esto
vale entonces vamos a movernos acá abajo
para tener un poco más de espacio y lo
primero que vamos a hacer es encontrar
una expresión para cada deere déjame
escribirlo por aquí abajo en la primera
integral de r entre dt está definido
como x prima de t por y + + de prima de
t x j
entonces vayamos a la segunda integral
en la curva que va al revés tenemos que
de r
/ dt es igual a y aquí tenemos que usar
la regla de la cadena vamos aquí arriba
queremos la derivada de x con respecto a
t eso es la derivada de lo de adentro es
decir menos 1 x la derivada de lo de
afuera evaluado en lo de adentro
entonces es menos 1 la derivada de lo de
adentro por la derivada de lo de afuera
evaluada en a más de lo de adentro por
iu y luego hay que hacer lo mismo con ye
verdad es la derivada de este término la
derivada de lo de adentro es menos 1 x
la derivada de lo de afuera evaluado en
lo de adentro es decir que prima de a
más de menos te lo escribimos aquí abajo
menos que prima de a b menos te por j
entonces queda esto y esto
respectivamente
pasemos ahora a escribir de r entonces
lo que vamos a hacer es multiplicar por
de t de r nos queda igual a x prima de t
más prima de té por j
y todo esto multiplicado por vete
podemos pensar desde como un escalar
aquí estamos haciendo algunos crímenes
matemáticos pero es más sencillo así
vamos acá de r es igual a menos x ya
cambié de verde pero no importa
x prima de ambas ve - t por y menos y
prima de amas ve - t por jota vale vamos
a multiplicar todo esto por de t ok
entonces ya estamos listos para expresar
la integral como una función desde
entonces está estar acá que nos queda
nos queda la integral de a a b que se
mueve de ave de f x de perdón
xd de coma 7
punto punto de r entonces drs es el de r
que calculamos acá lo cual es a ver ese
punto x prima de t
por y de prima de té por j y todo esto
de aquí tenemos que multiplicarlo por de
t
entonces vamos a ponerle vete listo
entonces pasamos a la segunda integral
ahora cuando hacemos la integral en el
lado contrario nos queda la integral de
ave de f de ahora no es x dt sino xd
t además ve - te estoy escribiendo en
pequeño para que quepa punto y entonces
hay que hacer un producto punto con este
ere es punto menos x prima de amas ve -
de x y menos menos de prima de ahí creo
que no va a caber déjame borrar un poco
para hacer algunos ajustes y que todo
quede mejor
de hecho como aquí tengo un menos y
tengo otro menos en el segundo sumando
entonces voy a cambiar esos menos hasta
afuera y luego ese menos
al ir porque es un valor escalar y vamos
a ponerlo afuera de pues digamos vamos a
ponerlo afuera de la integral entonces
lo ponemos hasta acá simplemente salió
del producto punto y de la integral y
luego tenemos x prima de hamás b - t
por más que prima de ab - t
voy a mover un poquito por j y todo eso
de té listo esta primera es la integral
de cuando recorremos la curva en sentido
normal y esta otra es cuando recorremos
la curva en dirección contraria ahora
como en el vídeo pasado vamos a hacer un
cambio de variable pero antes de eso
déjame recapitular aquí dice el producto
punto y luego simplemente saque el signo
menos que teníamos ese signo menos lo
pensé como un -1 tanto en de r como en
la integral pasamos a la substitución
queremos llegar a que esta integral es
la negativa de esta otra eso es lo que
nos dijo nuestra intuición entonces me
voy a enfocar en la integral de la
derecha déjame proponer la siguiente
sustitución vamos a ponerle sea un
iguala a más b - t el mismo truco del
vídeo pasado entonces de eeuu es igual a
menos de t
simplemente derivamos ambos lados o bien
podemos escribir que de t es igual a
menos de 1
entonces vamos a ver qué obtenemos
cuando hacemos este cambio primero
tenemos que ponerle si te es igual a a
entonces eso es igual a más ve -
entonces es igual a b esto es para
cambiar los límites de integración para
cuando te es igual a b entonces eso es
igual a más b b
entonces nos queda o igual a igual a
saleh entonces haciendo este cambio de
variable obtenemos la siguiente integral
a ver esta integral se hace igual a
menos la integral de iguala b verdad
ahora empezamos en b y terminamos en a
iguala de igual a igual a de f de x de
1,7
aquí tenemos y aquí también tenemos un
punto y ahora esta expresión de acá
entonces es a ver les voy a poner el
paréntesis y luego x prima
de un porn y esa es esta expresión más
de prima de un
por j y todo eso en vez de ponerle un dt
tenemos que ponerle un déu pero dt
dv entonces escribo menos de uno pero en
vez de poner el menos aquí pues voy a
poner de uno y ese menos sale sale sale
aquí se cancela con este menos y se
vuelve un más vamos a ponerle aquí un
más y ahora tú puedes estar pensando en
estas integrales parecen ser iguales no
parecen tener signo contrario y bueno
casi tienes razón
excepto que aquí tenemos los límites de
integración de una forma y acá de otra
entonces esta nueva integral que
encontramos tenemos todavía que voltear
los límites de integración y entonces
nos queda igual a menos la integral de a
a b d
efe de f de de que así de x de 1,7
punto
x prima de 1 x y más prima de 1
j d ahora sí esto es idéntico a esto
esta integral esta integral indefinida
es idéntica a la de acá la variables
distintas acá es tt y acá es de eeuu
pero como sólo la variable de
integración entonces vamos a obtener
exactamente los mismos valores si
ponemos la misma a la misma b el mismo
campo vectorial
efe y recorremos la misma trayectoria
dada por r vamos al resumen cuando
tenemos una integral de línea que está
definida en un campo vectorial eso es
importante verdad que f sea un campo
vectorial entonces la dirección si
importa si recorremos en el sentido
contrario obtenemos la versión negativa
esto es porque cuando cambiamos el
sentido la dirección de de r se invierte
y por tanto los productos puntos tienen
signos contrarios y qué trabalenguas
recordemos que si tenemos un campo
escalar esto no pasa eso lo vimos en el
vídeo anterior con un campo escalar no
nos importa la dirección del recorrido
daba lo mismo si recordamos o menos y
eso era porque estábamos intentando
encontrar un área
saleh espero que esto te haya parecido
al menos un poquito impresionante hasta
la próxima